ja die Absicht der geplanten
Ampelkoalition das Wahlalter abzusenken
vermutlich ist das Aktive Wahlalter
gemeint jedenfalls war von passiven
keine Rede von jetzt 18 auf 16 Jahren
halte ich für falsch warum weil Rechte
und Pflichten zusammengehören das kann
man nicht trennen und wenn der Staat
sagt also mit 16 Jahren Handyvertrag
abschließen geht gar nicht dafür fehlt
ja die reif für die Einsichtsfähigkeit
aber wählen über weitreichende
politische Entwicklung und
Entscheidungen mit abstimmen zu können
das trauen wir den jungen Menschen schon
zu das halte ich für einen Widerspruch
in sich natürlich können auch junge
Menschen mit 16 17 Jahren politisch
interessiert sein politisch engagiert
sein etwas bewegen wollen können 14 und
15-jährige aber auch deshalb meine These
die zivilrechtlichen Pflichten aber auch
die strafrechtliche Verantwortlichkeit
die sollten wir genauso behandeln wie
das Wahlrecht auch
zumindest nachher bei 18 Jahren belastet
ja Herr Bosbach ich kann ihnen
eigentlich nicht widersprechen über mich
wundert's dass sie als CDU-Politiker so
kurz nach diesem fehlenden Wahlergebnis
direkt drauf gehen ich meine wir kennen
alle die Zahlen wie sich jungen Wähler
wie sich Erstwähler entschieden haben zu
dem allergrößten Teil nicht für die CDU
und anstatt den Menschen Angebot zu
machen zumindest so zu tun als würde man
darüber nachdenken ob in die jungen
Menschen nicht wählen lassen kann direkt
eine Watsche
um und sagen und nächstes Mal mache ich
mein Kreuz garantiert Wohnig bei der
Union was kann man in doppelter Hinsicht
anders sehen erstens unterstellt ja dass
alle das genauso sehen aber auch viele
Jugendliche finden das nicht richtig und
das zweite ist das ist ja der Grund
natürlich wissen die Genossen und die
Grünen und die Erfahrung die FDP dass
sie überdurchschnittlich gut
abgeschnitten haben wenn das nicht der
Fall gewesen wäre wären sie gar nicht
auf die Idee gekommen mit der Absenkung
oder das entscheidende Argument ist die
Kop der vollen Geschäftsfähigkeit mit
dem Wahlrecht ist völlig unlogisch zu
sagen Wahlen ja aktives Wahlrecht ja
aber auf keine volle Geschäftsfähigkeit
die sagen die jungen Leute wollen gar
nicht wählen weil worauf bezahlen es
gibt ja Umfragen über verschiedene
Altersgruppen und und ja und richtig ist
je höher das Alter desto stärker die
Ablehnung das geht bis 70 80 Prozent
Ablehnung aber es ist nicht so dass alle
zwischen 16 und 20 sofort dafür sind das
so tatsächlich hätte ich jetzt gedacht
ja das heißt in der Erfindung der
Parteien die davon profitieren nein da
haben wir ja schon lange die
Kommunalwahlrecht ist ja schon ab 18
Jahre abgesenkt aber versuche jetzt 16
bitte
waren sie dafür oder dagegen dafür da
waren sie dafür wieso soll man kommunal
wählen das ist der der Erlebnisraum in
dem ich lebe wo ich meine Entscheidung
jeden Tag nachvollziehen kann wo ich
auch ganz anders konfrontiert bin mit
den ganz alltäglichen Entscheidungen die
in der Kommunalpolitik getroffen werden
und bei dem bei dem Wahlrecht zur
Bundestagswahl oder zu den
Landtagswahlen da geht es um ganz andere
politische Themen und Fragestellungen
wer das machen will jeder soll dann auch
das
geschäftsfähigkeitsalter auf 16 Jahre
absenken wenn das das Argument ist die
Einsichtsfähigkeit ist ausreichend
ausgeprägt wieso brauche ich beim
Handyvertrag mehr Einsichtsfähigkeit als
beim
wahlrechtsregierung
verkündet hätte so ab 16 jetzt los zum
Wählen nein weil ich 16 für zu früh
halte einfach ich finde es ich versuche
das Argument von Herrn Bosbach zu
verstehen mit der Geschäftsfähigkeit für
mich macht das Sinn gleichzeitig
verstehe ich nicht wirklich warum man
mit 16 kommunal wählen kann ich verstehe
der persönliche Lebensraum ist
erlebbarer aber und damit 18 nicht aber
ich halte 18 für absolut für ausreichend
für die Bundestagswahlen weil man da
sicherlich auch ein fest aus mindset hat
und sonst kann man auch sagen mit 15 mit
14 warum ich auch mit 13 dann ist nach
unten keine keine Grenze gesetzt dich
wir müssen natürlich auch wissen dass
diejenigen die
älter sind zwischen 50 und 70 fast
doppelt so viel sind wie die die
ab 30 nach von 18 bis 30 sind und
deswegen kann man vielleicht sagen okay
wir holen uns noch ein bisschen was dazu
vielleicht aktivieren wir Menschen auch
weil die zum zum größeren Teil eben
nicht wählen gehen aber das ist kein
Mittel was funktionieren wird bin ich
fröst von überzeugt das geht vielleicht
mal eine Wahl so und dann nicht mehr
nein ich finde 18 sollte bleiben wir
haben ja schon Differenzierung auch zum
Beispiel beim Strafrecht
gilt ja das Jugendstrafrecht weiter auch
wenn ich schon volljährig 15
ja da bin ich straffällig richtig aber
ich sage jetzt nur ich bin ja ich kann
nach dem Jugendstrafrecht also jetzt ich
denke jetzt gerade umgekehrt ich kann
nach dem Jugendstrafrecht bestraft
werden auch wenn ich schon älter bin so
das heißt also diese diese 18er Grenze
gilt ja nicht überall Europe
erstmal haben sie recht aber das Gesetz
sagt das Gegenteil wer über 18 ist nach
dem erwachsenen Strafrecht und der
Ausnahme soll das mildere
Jugendstrafrecht sein Spruchpraxis
Freiheit aber pro Argumente zum Einbauen
also ein Argument natürlich vorher was
macht könnte ja sein dass wenn die
Jugendlichen ab 16 wählen dürfen dann
könnt ihr das Pro Argument sein da ist
auch mehr auf die Jugendlichen geachtet
wird dass die Interessen der
Jugendlichen werden und das Interesse
ist ja gerade existenziell
tja irgendwo muss man ja anfangen
ja gut aber das sehen die jungen
Menschen nur immer sehr anders und sie
sagen der Erlebnisraum ist die Kommune
in der man sich ausprobieren soll die
jungen Menschen würden ganz anders
argumentieren die wollen nämlich gerade
zumindest zum gewissen Teil die Welt
retten und das beginnt halt nicht damit
dass irgendwie eine neue Straße im Dorf
gebaut wird sondern das beginnt damit
dass Deutschland früher aus der Kohle
aussteigt oder den Verbrenner früher
verbietet davon fühlen die sich
existenziell bedroht zumindest ganz
viele und das wollen wir 14 15 jährige
auch
12-jährige 13-jährige die damit laufen
und das zu ihrem Thema machen
die Grüne Jugend sagt ja im ersten
Schritt wenn man es auf 16 absetzen im
ersten Schritt aber nur und dann weiter
runter also auch das Paras auch
politische Forderungen man braucht halt
irgendwelche Zahlen die man rein
schreibt man kann nicht sagen irgendwas
sondern gut sagt halt wir sind gerade
bei 18 jetzt bei 16 und dann schauen wir
mal weiter so läuft das normal ja gut
aber wir wollen sie ja Ernst wir wollen
sie ja ernst nehmen wir wollen ja nicht
sagen die schreiben da irgendwelche
Zahlen rein sollen wir sagen die haben
sich was bei gedacht und Sie haben ja
recht erwusst war wieso 16 wie gekommen
wieso nicht 17 ich glaube
Leute
aber warum 16 sagen Sie mal so 16 warum
ist immer ein bisschen schwierig ich bin
auch definitiv für das Wahlrecht ab 18
aber ich finde dieses Argument zu sagen
die die Interessen wird dann
berücksichtigt werden schon richtig und
ich finde konservativ zum Beispiel
bedeutet ja auch etwas anzuschauen aufs
Exempel zu schauen und dann vielleicht
auch zu verändern nicht das alles beim
Alten bleiben muss und zum Beispiel beim
Führerschein wurde ja von 18 auf 17
geändert dass jugendlich auch schon mit
17 mit den Eltern ein Jahr fahren
konnten und dann alleine aber man konnte
den Führerschein halt auch schon mit 16
halt machen für 17 Lebensjahr das fand
ich zum Beispiel eine gute Entwicklung
da haben vielleicht auch vorher Leute
gesagt nee also mit 17 Sitzen die wir
die aber noch nicht anstrengend mit den
Eltern zusammen mit 17 das wäre
vielleicht sein ich glaube man könnte ja
schon sagen wenn die Jugend ist ja auch
politischer geworden also das beweisen
ja auch wirklich Studien das heißt
vielleicht einfach mal schauen Sie damit
politischer geworden interessieren sich
mehr für Politik als früher
also die Jugend ist schon politisierter
weswegen ich dann schon sagen würde wir
können ja schon mal gucken ob nicht
vielleicht ein oder zwei Jahre vorher ob
es nicht auch einfach verändert hat zu
früher ich war gerade das ganze
Wochenende bei der Jungen Union in
Münster auf dem Deutschlandtag und da
waren sehr viele hervorragende junge
Menschen ich habe mir jetzt nicht von
jedem den Personalausweis zeigen lassen
also ich weiß nicht wie alt die alle
waren aber die tun der Union wahnsinnig
gut sind wahnsinnig klar im Kopf und
aber alle stramm gegen das Wahl gegen
die Absenkung des Wahlalters das hat
mich dann dann doch überrascht verstehen
junge Menschen und heizen den
parteiborsten wirklich ein aber wenn es
darum geht dass das junge Menschen
wählen sollen bloß nicht und was war das
Hauptargument dagegen ich glaube das ist
vor allem das von von Herrn Bosbach
Rechte und Pflichten und das muss
zusammen gehen bei Demokratie sowas
heiliges ist man kann nicht das
Heiligtum den Menschen anvertrauen aber
die Geschäftsfähigkeit kommt dann
entsprechend
[Musik]